the scars of conflict offer all to see
in coventry
but from the ruins of war has grown a
city of sanctuary
these afghan refugees thought they'd
found peace when they fled afghanistan
but they worry for relatives left behind
the taliban isn't the only threat
the famine that is absolutely
showing that it's coming
and it will have quite a big impact on
the people's livelihood
and
i'm just worried that it's going to be a
human catastrophe
human crisis yeah because of
this crisis
all the food and everything grocery us
getting expensive on the other hand
there is no money to buy it so the life
getting tougher day by day back in
afghanistan
drought and a crumbling economy means
that more than half of afghanistan's
population could face famine this winter
charities distributing aid there say
drastic action is needed
afghanistan is heading towards one of
the worst humanitarian crises in its
history the drought that has been
lasting uh now for two to three years
and that's affecting 80 percent of uh
the country is leading to a situation
where uh the little food that
afghanistan was producing um is is not
being produced and at the same time
borders are shut um and therefore the
little that is in country um is not
enough to to feed people
in 1999 sabia first made his home in
coventry after escaping taliban rule
i think the world needs to remember
afghanistan at this time i think there
is a real need for collaboration a
global collaboration to help and support
afghanistan through this difficult
moment because
it's not often just bullets that take
lives it's famine as well
[Music]
nearly 19 million people are already
facing starvation in afghanistan
without more help experts say the crisis
will escalate
lisa dowd sky news